yesterday congressional Republicans
unveiled their plan to replace Obamacare
it's called the American Health Care Act
it's basically just a wet sock filled
with ibuprofen and a post-it note that
says good luck ha but jason Chaffetz the
Utah Republican congressman who looks
like a rescue Ranger with a GI Joe doll
haircut defended the proposal on CNN
this morning in a way that would make
marie-antoinette proud Americans have
choices and they've got to make a choice
and so maybe rather than getting that
new iPhone that they just love and they
want to go spend hundreds of dollars
that maybe they should invested in their
own health care they've got to make
those decisions themselves yeah
q millennial yeah if you just forego
that $749 iPhone 7 you can literally pay
for 2% of an appendectomy ha ha I got a
long time using health care in that
sweet new iPhones you want to use it the
Dust Bowl photo lady now Bork what she
has an iPhone 3 of course it's a member
of Congress dis melt into the rock
popsicle get ha ha ha
sweet sweet subsidized government health
care but not only that it turns out
James's political action committee pays
for his Verizon bill
comedians what's another of his
money-saving tips for people without
health care but you could save money on
gas for your commute by dying in your
sleep
[Laughter]
[Applause]
no more premium yeah point yeah if you
hold your breath long enough God will
take care of everything else
yes man at least at least that's how I
got my iPhone yeah very good okay
one small penis removal surgery will
save tons of money on viagra yeah
absolutely
- Whoopi and lawyers fee